absolutely insane nft sponsor offer the
amounts are astronomical it was even
more fun to tell them no he turned down
a 1.2 million nft sponsorship oh my god
xqc is leading the charge against what
he calls scummy nfts after it was
revealed that he turned down a pretty
big offer to promote some nfts the offer
itself 1.2 million dollars for some
tweets a couple of shout outs and an
overlay that's a that's a racket that is
a racket if i ever seen one no thank you
sir man i mean should be surprising
though there's a bunch of them it's it's
just it's just how nfts are man
now x isn't alone in that opinion major
streamers like hassanabe pokemane and
asmingold have showed disdain towards
the shadier side of nfts the one thing
that was good about the art was at least
it's supposed to make you feel something
these apes are everything but that also
nfts are fake